für Scarlet und Maddie ist hier ihr
Wohlfühlort im beruhigenden Gespräch mit
Psychotherapeutin Linsi Flemming seit
sie sieben Jahre alt ist GIZ Scarlett zu
Therapeuten um mit Stress klar zu kommen
mit negativen Gefühlen mit Panikattacken
Scarlet und Maddie sind erst 17 und
empfinden doch schon ständigen Druck
Leistungsdruck das Gefühl perfekt sein
zu müssen stark befördert von der
künstlichen Welt der sozialen Medien
so spar und denkst
da als ich
und dünner als ich du vergleichst dich
mit ihnen und denkst du bist so viel
weniger wert als sie und das ist immer
schwer und nicht gut
es ist so ein Wettbewerb unter den
Mädchen jede wird besser sein als die
andere und dann sieht man auf dem Handy
Videos wie andere zusammen Spaß haben
und denkt oh sie machen so tolle Sachen
ohne mich und dann fühlt man sich
schlecht und fragt sich was mache ich
falsch wie kann ich mich ändern so dass
ich auch dabei sein kann
laut einer Studie der US-Regierung
fühlen sich drei von fünf Teenagern
permanent traurig jedes dritte Mädchen
hat demnach bereits ernsthaft über
Suizid nachgedacht
Lindsey Flemming möchte keine
Möglichkeit ungenutzt lassen deshalb
geht die junge Therapeutin auch dahin wo
ihre jugendlichen Patientinnen und
Patienten sind auf tiktok so viel
Schlechtes begegne den Jugendlichen dort
so viel was ihren Selbstwert beschädigt
und sie überfordert legen sie will dem
etwas entgegensetzen
du hast den Gedanken ich bin wertlos
Gedanken sind keine Fakten löse dich von
ihnen
[Musik]
aus reden auf der Plattform ja schon so
viele über psychische Gesundheit da
möchte ich wenigstens jemand sein vom
Fach die darüber redet die ausgebildet
ist ich versuche ein Vorbild zu sein
dafür wie man die Plattform besser
nutzen kann wir brauchen dort anerkannte
Fachleute
für Susi Barthel ist der Kampf um das
psychische Wohlergehen von Jugendlichen
persönlich vor neun Jahren hat sich ihr
Sohn Ryan das Leben genommen die
trauernde Mutter hat im Andenken an ihn
eine Stiftung gegründet die Programme
durchführt um gefährdete Jugendliche
aufzufangen niemand soll sich so
verloren und allein fühlen wie ihr Sohn
ist hart
sie müssen sich angenommen fühlen ganz
gleich wer sie sind überall werden sie
beurteilt sie werden in der Schule
beurteilt von ihren Lehrern beurteilt zu
Hause beurteilt wir versuchen eine
Umgebung zu schaffen wo das Wichtigste
ist dass sie akzeptiert werden du kannst
sein wer immer du sein willst wir werden
dich nicht beurteilen
vielen Kindern hier sieht man ihre
dunklen Gedanken nicht an die
gesellschaftliche Krise ist auf den
ersten Blick unsichtbar selbst Tötung
ist in den USA die zweithäufigste
Todesart bei 15 bis 24-Jährigen es gibt
jetzt 50% mehr Suizide in dieser
Altersgruppe als vor 20 Jahren
Kamel litt unter dem aggressiven
Lebensgefährten ihrer Mutter hinzu kamen
starker Leistungsdruck durch die Eltern
während der corona-pandemie war sie dann
von allem abgeschnitten was Ausgleich
verschaffte
durch das virtuelle lernen konnte ich
meine Freunde kaum noch sehen ich konnte
keine neuen Leute kennenlernen ich habe
jede Sozialkompetenz verloren das musste
ich danach wieder erlernen es war als
wäre das alles ganz neu für mich
Annika wird in der Schule von dem
gleichaltrigen ausgeschlossen gegängelt
hier in der Gruppe findet sie eine
Gemeinschaft wie sie sie vorher gar
nicht kannte
[Musik]
in der Schule sind sie richtig gemein zu
mir
komische hier sind alle lieb niemand
gibt mir blöde Spitznamen hier gehöre
ich einfach dazu weil ich eben nicht
viele Freunde habe bin ich froh dass
mich hier alle akzeptieren
Susi Bartel hat mit der Stiftung ihre
Lebensaufgabe gefunden
wenn ich die Reaktion der Jugendlichen
hier beobachte und sehe dass sie die
Kurve kriegen nachdem Sie unsere
Programme durchlaufen haben
das ist fast wie eine Erlösung für mich
es ist
wenigstens habe ich meinen Teil dazu
beigetragen dass andere Kinder nicht den
gleichen Weg beschreiten wie Ryan
ein Ryans Schule hat sich seit seinem
Tod alles verändert gemeinsam mit der
Stiftung seiner Mutter hat sie ein
umfassendes Programm entwickelt es gibt
einen Schülerclub zum Thema mental
health der auch Veranstaltungen
organisiert wie diesen Tag der
psychischen Gesundheit hier können die
Schüler in entspannter Atmosphäre
erfahren welche Möglichkeiten und
Angebote es für Betroffene gibt die
woodgrave Highschool beschäftigt einen
Schulpsychologen zwei beratende Coaches
einen Sozialarbeiter sie wollen hier
keinen mehr verlieren auch die
US-Regierung hat das Problem erkannt und
will verstärkt Gelder zur Verfügung
stellen
Henna Edwards betont wie wichtig das ist
und wie das schulische Angebot ihr
persönlich geholfen hat
als ich etwa in der zehnten Klasse war
habe ich herausgefunden dass ich wohl
Autistin bin das war wirklich
beängstigend
aber hier habe ich viel darüber gelernt
wie ich meine Stärken einsetzen kann und
mich und meine psychische Gesundheit
kümmern kann und dass das meine
Lebensqualität deutlich verbessert
Grove Highschool will mit ihrem leicht
zugänglichen Angebot auch ein Beispiel
für viele weiteren Schulen sein damit
die Gesellschaft ihre jugendlichen nicht
im Stich lässt